but wanna you say you've been holding on
to the screenplay for the angry black
girl and her monster since 2018 and was
getting rejected a lot can you take us
through the full journey of the script I
mean like
I mean it's one of those it's a I guess
it's a classic Hollywood Story you know
where the script is kind of making the
rounds and people are just like nah I'm
good uh you know and they're just
passing on it you know so it was just
kind of years of
uh of dealing with that until finally
you know [__] TV read it and engaged
were they giving you any notes who uh
the people that were passing on it nope
they just said it's a pass that's all
yeah yeah that was it uh they don't
really I mean I guess I can't blame
people for this like do you have time to
like give a docket you know it's like if
you don't even feel like the script's
worth engaging on why would you give any
like notes
I guess I mean I'm just I'm not an
executive so I don't know
how are you getting the script out for
people to read
um it was mainly my manager he was the
one kind of
pushing it out there
um and I did get like meetings you know
but they were kind of like
it was one of those things where they're
like oh we uh because the people who
liked the script they were like yeah we
like this script but we want you to
write something else for us because we
liked the script so it was like it was
really weird I don't know how that
happens but you know whatever
so they didn't necessarily want this
script but they liked your style they
liked your storytelling and they said
please do something else and you your
answer was
uh I mean I think with someone I um I
pursued it for a little while but you
know it kind of just fell apart you know
yeah there was like there was like two
projects that kind of just
fell apart you know I think one of them
was wrapped up in an adaptation of some
uh some comic book that like the the the
writer of the comic book like the rights
to it went back to them and they didn't
feel like engaging with them anymore and
so then you know my script kind of just
went away because now they don't have
the rights and yeah so it was just like
there's just like stories like that
what year did [__] TV say yes uh it was
2020 I believe okay so two years it's
floating around you're getting no you're
not knowing why interesting yeah
how do they let you know they had
interest in the script uh my manager
called me and was like yo there's this
company
he's like can you make the movie for x
amount or whatever you know from micro
budget or whatever and I was like
I mean yeah I'm not gonna say no to that
you know it's like so
um he was like all right well
you know they want to meet with you you
know have like a general conversation
you know so she's going to call you at
this time on this day so be ready to
take that call and we'll see where it
goes and I was like all right and so
they called me we had like a
conversation and then uh I guess they I
guess she liked me enough you know so as
they set up a pitch meeting for uh for
them you know for the movie and like you
know then I pitched them and then I
guess they took to that too so here we
are so then you actually did have a
meeting where you're like pulling onto
the lot and yeah well Zoom because covet
yeah so I was kind of just walking them
through my PowerPoint
yeah what went into your pitch
um it was a couple things it was just
like
you know uh the vibe and the style of
the story how I want to tell it
um it was also like I cut together a
little Sizzle reel of just like a bunch
of different uh movies together to kind
of give them a Vibe of just like the
moment of bringing you know the the
creature back to life and
um with like music to kind of give the
official tone that I'm looking for here
um and
what else was in that pitch
um yeah it was just in general just like
about the movie like how I how I
envisioned the movie and walking them
through uh through that through every
step of just like the story itself to
you know the style of acting to the
style of editing to the style of um of
the music and uh what I'm trying to
capture and then like movie references
of the people who I felt like uh movies
that were closest to it that I wanted to
capture
and were they giving you feedback or
they were just listening and then the
feedback came later
feedback is in like we hate this or we
like this or we want more of this can we
can we ramp this part up nah they were
just kind of like
they you know they asked me like some
kind of questions I forgot exactly what
they asked me you know that it wasn't I
mean I don't want to say it wasn't
important but it's like in the grand
scheme of things it wasn't they were
just kind of like you know they just had
certain questions about uh things on a
bad way but they were just kind of
inquiring more about stuff and then
um
and yeah that was like that was kind of
it they didn't really say any critically
I guess because they liked the pitch so
and then once you pitch them how soon
did you hear back that it was a go
um they started engaging pretty quickly
after that
you know
um because I heard from my manager my
lawyer you know it's like they kind of
started sending deal points you know so
like they started engaging pretty
quickly
and so you're like this is really
happening yeah it was weird because
I don't know like people talk about the
waves of like I guess happiness or
whatever like when you're trying to make
a movie and like at this moment you
shouldn't like I'm not gonna say it
doesn't mean [__] it does you've gotten
to another level but but technically
speaking in the grand scheme of making a
movie when someone options your script
or whatever you know it's just like it
doesn't really it means something but in
the grand scheme of things doesn't mean
[__] like you know it's like it can it
can all still fall apart pretty quickly
you know people get their scripts
optioned all the time and it doesn't go
anywhere and then like it falls apart
but for me
nothing ever felt as good as that moment
and you know obviously this movie is
doing a lot of crazy stuff as of right
now you know
um that's not to [__] on the other
moments I still had a great time but for
whatever reason the height of the
excitement hit a really hard like it
went really high for that moment because
I was like yeah man yeah
do you think the trajectory of your
script was common do you think that all
the ups and downs all the no's you think
that's just what every screenwriter goes
through I mean [__] it sounds like it
it's like kind of because every story
when I was like uh watching and
listening and looking up to other
filmmakers that I love like seems like
that was like the a common thing you
know people just being like yeah you
hear no a lot so like feels like that's
part of it feels pretty cliche to me
like you know but when you're going
through it you know you don't think
about that or at least I didn't
have you always been more of a realist
um with outcomes
I get I mean I I can't deny I do have
some idealism to me with things on how I
want to do stuff I think I think you
kind of have to right like uh that's
what happened to the vision for
something is and that's not just even
saying as a director it's like even when
you're writing something or whatever
it's just like what you want the story
to be on the page but you know it might
come out different but you still have a
vision which means there's like idealism
in that right
um but with uh with other things you
know I I think there's some realism
approaches that I feel because I wrote
another script while I was waiting so
it's not like I was just like this is my
only one and it's gonna happen and you
know it's like I was like well am I not
so and I need more than one idea so I'm
writing another one that came to me as
well
ultimately why did the buyers choose
your script
um
I wish I knew I I cannot there's only
like certain data or like slight
information I hear from them that makes
me
uh think that has something to do with
it I mean they I think they think is the
original idea that they believed in and
it was in the same vein of the type of
stuff that Crypt was making uh as well
as they also tell me that they really
loved my pitch uh and I think they liked
me because I hope they do you know so
it's like I think a combination of those
things probably is what took it through
the roof because
filmmaking is a it's a marathon you know
and I think even if you like an idea and
even if you like a pitch when you're
dealing with someone for I mean 2020 we
engaged movie finished in 2022 right
like that's two years right it's like
and if you don't like them like I can
only imagine it'll make these other two
parts uh you liking the idea and the
pitch or whatever like difficult and be
forgotten because you're dealing with
someone that you don't like so I I hope
that I was you know I can only hope that
so
and when most people get a job they
never ask them why did you choose me
yeah yeah exactly so maybe in a
relationship yeah not not for a job yeah
yeah how much script work did you have
to do before the movie was made once
they said yes
were they giving you notes revisions
yeah I mean I had they had their notes
for uh the draft that came in that they
were you know that we were engaging with
uh so they had their rounded notes that
I did then they took that out and then
like um then as we were leading up to
production then we were kind of going
through uh notes uh like as we were
leading up to production just because I
think you know once the once it's about
to happen you know you start looking at
it with a more scrutinizing eye so all
of us were kind of just you know dialing
in giving notes on and you know trying
to make it the best possible version it
can before we into production because
once you start putting it on film or on
digital or whatever it's like that's it
you know so it's like you want to go in
with a what's your strongest foot
forward
were there any revisions while you were
filming did they say you know what can
we change this line of dialogue
not really I don't think we had time or
money it's like the resources were slim
so
um of course there's like when you're
filming
that you adapt you know of course there
were changes because we're in a location
now we have actors now who you know who
are saying things and doing things and
you might be like oh this is actually
working better without X you know so
that will happen but as far as just
being like Oh rewrite this or whatever
and none of that happened what advice do
you have for screenwriters who say that
selling a screenplay is impossible
it's not impossible I'll say that
because I'm sitting here now and I was
watching y'all's videos looking for
advice so uh it's wild to me that I'm
sitting here right now talking to you so
I think that it's not impossible I think
it's it's it's it's it's definitely
probable and it's achievable I did it
and I know that sounds cliche but I'm
telling you like I said this is really
meta for me like I was sitting on the
other side watching this videos of this
very Channel film courage with people
giving advice and stuff like that and
it [__] happened for me so